foreign
[Music]
hey guys uh we're here live coming to
you live from the CR from the
congratulations studio crystalia uh I am
going to be in Nashville and Little Rock
this weekend uh get your ticket to
crystallia.com and then I will also be
in Canada coming up in Cleveland and
Vermont I think and uh Detroit go to
chrisley.com bunch of different cities
uh there are there is amazing merch
there at crystalia.com if you go and you
can get the pocket stay deep uh hoodie
and
um Regular t-shirt you got the uh the
pocket the uh the diving board on the
pocket to let people know that you got
money let people know that you've got a
bunch of uh Deep Pockets and willing to
spend on everything anything anything uh
you anything and look at that look at
that fabric look at that absolute
beautiful fabric made by the pockets
stay deep and then we've got the grower
die merch which is absolutely One of a
Kind look at that even though there's
two and there's two different versions
you got the dying rose on it there
absolutely beautiful grow or die
um so go to chrysalia.com to get that
merch and let them know
um
and also welcome to the new episode of
congratulations
[Music]
we in it dude we built this in it brown
pick it Brown let's start by watching
this
is Steve Ballmer at dot at net
presentate
.net presentation developers
headquarters and this is old and this is
in a [__] amazing thing I don't know
if I don't think I've ever talked about
this
first of all guy doesn't get out okay
much also
this is like the first time he hasn't
been drunk in [__] like three months
this I mean sweating so much it's
unbelievable
this guy was the like a like a Steve
Jobs type guy
in Microsoft for Microsoft though
just a [__] Will Ferrell character
straight up
you know he's getting started the anger
already the the vitriol
so what is such a specific question and
went through puberty at the same time
just just such a specific question that
nobody has ever been asked ever or even
thought about and then went through
puberty immediately so it's all good
the beginning of it
okay
so what is 14.64
question
holy cow I'm gonna have to touch almost
right here we go
64 000 question for the field
what the hell are we supposed to do
about this Steve
it's a very good question
honestly a guy like this you look at
this at what he's doing how's he alive
he is he still alive
unbelievable dude unbelievable
here we go
oh my Developers
the key a musical.net the key to
Industry Transit seven notes in one key
to success is developers developers
developers developers Developers
a developer [__] his wife and knows
he's [__] her right now
knows they're on a date right now and
there's nothing you do with it
completely emotional
everyone's so weirded out Beauty and
this guy owns the Clippers now this is
unbelievable
okay dude knows his wife has slept with
three different developers the whole
time
I said you know what I'm not going to do
the developers developers Developers
no matter what happens I'm not doing the
developers developers developers thing
that he thought he was going to do and
then he was like I'm not going to do
that because it's too much and then
realized one second before the okay that
he was going to be doing it
okay
so what is and this
is actually the reason that made him
change into okay I'm going to do the
developers developers developers thing
is I'm going to start it with the 64 000
I found a way in he thought
I found a way in and he did it and he
did it with the 64 000 questions here we
go
here we go
okay
so what is the 64 000 question
almost threw up
his hair stops
he is bald it's unbelievable when guys
are so
immediately bald like they're just like
hair hair hair hair
stop no gradualness just immediately
stop and then [__] shiny cue ball
like that [__] um
what's the [__] in uh Dope Sick the guy
they had the terrible bald wig the bald
cap on him it just was so bad this is
what it looked like
we what the hell are we gonna throw up
Steve
ate so much Chinese food the night
before
very clear
Developers
the key to dot net the key to Industry
the key to success is developers
developers developers first developers
on a date right now with his wife
dude developers developers Developers
oh gonna cry dude I mean I actually
think a developer did [__] his wife I'm
not even bullshitting that guy's
unbelievable
oh that guy's unbelievable
oh yes got me look at this thing on
BuzzFeed a viral discussion about men
smashing cake in their partner's faces
has taken over the Internet because
quite frankly women are fed up bye
bye
overall discussion about men smashing
cake in there this is what the title
should be a variable a viral discussion
about men smashing cake in their
partner's faces has taken over the
Internet because quite frankly women are
fed up by
there's footage of some men literally
tackling down their Brides just to shove
cake in their faces and it's not cool
all right well yeah dude of course 100
don't ever tackled your wife right
I mean dude I'm imagining like a horror
movie like nah now and he's just like
Crawling After with a cake like a piece
of cake and she's like get away get him
[__] away
um
in a world where viral where where
smashing cake in your partner's face has
taken over the has taken over the world
it's sexist now now
smashing people's what's wrong with me
smashing kick in people's faces
particularly women's faces I love it
dude I love how they make it a [__]
dude the women do it to the men too
particularly women's faces has been a
topic can't you just see an annoying
[__] saying this like uh behind some
Podium smashing cake in people's faces
particularly women's faces okay
has been a topic that has been around
for a long time and has often talked
about when discussing wedding trends
that people hate
um
BuzzFeed dude
smashing cake in each other's faces uh
is one though I will be paying this I
will be paying a lot of money for the
dress makeup hair and the cake so don't
smash it in my face it's old and frankly
rude when it comes when couples shove it
up there significant others knows am I
the one only one who feels this way
that's what somebody said ah somebody on
Tick Tock said ah what do you know
somebody [__] annoying on tick tock
um
well dude obviously look at this getting
a kick special interface by her husband
at her son's first birthday party is
generating a lot of this is a thing uh
video
I was very hurt I remember I immediately
went to the bathroom clean up myself up
and FaceTime my dad bawling Jesus okay
let's do this
it looks like the perfect family
gathering let's see this also weirdo the
guy just any any it's not even a [__]
wedding it does the kids for his
birthday any any type of cakes around I
so much guy hates his wife that's how he
lets it out on him on her
and a yummy cake it's right in front of
him for his birthday dad helps him taste
the icing and encourages him to just go
for it and dig in with his hands he's so
cute
everybody you know has their child do a
case for the first birthday but the
unexpected happens dad picks up wait so
you can clearly hear me say no
yup candy mulroy of Tampa
I thought he wanted me not a big deal
dude this is the woman this is the wife
of this guy
she's talking to Inside Edition about it
hey you gotta go home later
s gonna be
because it was coming at me with this
cake and then well I'm wearing it this
was nice are you kidding are you
absolutely
who cares lady people are dying in
Rwanda why is going on
you remember that scene where Don
Cheadle is in hotel and Rhonda racing
after the bus that's real yeah Don
cheadle's a you know an actor that's got
more than millions of dollars but that's
the scene that really happens and you're
worried about this [__] chicky dude
I immediately went to the bathroom
cleaned myself up I I FaceTime my dad
obviously you have other issues you know
what I'm saying
posted the video she captioned it if he
does this ever again he won't live to
talk it's okay the reaction is setting
social media oh my God imagine imagine
her serving him serving her serving
divorce papers to him because of this
get out he lightly put it on her face
well you are a [__] trainwrecker over
this and by the way you know [__] oh
dude I wish he did it I wish he did it
hey I was just trying to have a good
time and play a joke on her and I I put
a cake on her face a little bit
um
I guess she didn't like it
how do you feel about you know I kind of
you think he's very embarrassed no [__]
because you're being a [__] [__]
about it
[Music]
oh wow look at this she politely said no
and he did it anyway
smashing cakes in people's faces stop
being funny after age 10.
it especially needs to be addressed when
men are blatantly ignoring their
partner's course this is a wild man
look at this these men are literally
tackling their Brides down just to throw
a cake in their face like are they I've
never seen a video of a of a man running
after a woman like like [__] Michael
Myers
instead with a knife he's equipped with
a a slice of you know strawberry vanilla
cake
look at this immediate divorce immediate
would walk right out
BuzzFeed [__] get a grip come on dude
what is this one
dear this was on Reddit
dear prude Dear Prudence I got married
just before Christmas and I'm hoping to
be divorced and annulled by the end of
January obviously that wasn't the plan
originally but I never cared about
getting married but I wasn't opposed to
it so when my boyfriend was in 2020 we
decided to go for it we each took on
about half responsibility for organized
wedding but I think it was pretty
reasonable about compromise when he
really wanted something my heart
okay
being a reasonable man who knows me well
he didn't instead okay so hold on so
um
okay okay my only hard and fast rule was
that he would not rub cake in my face at
the reception being a reasonable man who
knows me well he didn't instead he
grabbed me by the back of the head and
shove my head down into it it was
planned since the cake was destroyed and
we had a bunch of cupcakes as backup oh
wow okay I left next day I told him we
were done I am standing by that the
thing is that over the holidays everyone
has gotten together to tell me I should
give him a second chance that I'm
overreacted because of my issues
I mean
maybe I would say give him a second
chance that's pretty [__] crazy there
are other problems oh you didn't want to
get married okay
well
okay
hey they'll learn won't they
what's this
hold on hold on
hold on dude
we gotta Christian songs that shouldn't
go hard but do
who gives us new life these never go
hard a new thing everyone always thinks
these kind of things go hard they don't
go hard
[Music]
donut
new thing you can always Donuts what's
the new thing
the way he's dressed
[Music]
yo who's doing it
my God is doing a brand new thing with
this time began he Remains the Same
faithful I'm gonna do his work and
silence according
um God is doing a new thing
God doesn't change but he knows the time
from Hope what's the new thing God's
doing
I mean God is doing a new thing oh oh
never held a microphone before his life
oh it's insecure oh dude in the middle
of Jesus
Christ dude here's the thing man uh
God's not doing a new thing okay the
world's going to [__] God's not not even
doing the old thing no God's not doing
the thing okay period there's like
people who are dying uh uh tsunamis and
[__] earthquakes and and and and and
I mean for [__] sake Los Angeles had a
hurricane the other day God's not doing
a new thing the only thing God doing the
new thing is a bad thing okay God shape
up that's the song that should be God
Shape Up This world's a travesty God
[__] a J-pop where the [__] are ya
I'm about to be non-Christian
die through our music we're doing our
new thing so he can use it got using
this music and the common strong Michael
Clinton y'all singing this song to make
a thing about the way that you live and
that you know Christ is the one who will
give peace in your heart a new start
coming out the door and he'll do it you
know what this song sucks but the guy's
outfit is pretty hard the outfit goes
hard the dancing girl the dancing and
they just cut off some disrespectful
dude that is uh God is not doing a new
thing that that song does not go hard
that kid his outfit goes so hard I can't
even believe it
um
uh
yeah
just absolutely [__]
I can't believe all of these all these
these [__] tabloids now that they're
not just in the supermarket that you
have to see them when you scroll past
Instagram and [__] are just unbelievable
and it's always they're they're always
the the biggest hyperbole shits it's
like
like this one here
Kanye West's wife Bianca sensori it's
Italian can't stop wearing naked outfits
made from see-through tights can't stop
like it's a [__] condition
you know
like she's just like I would love to
honestly but um the way my mind and body
works I even if I put on something that
is not see-through it immediately
becomes see-through and nude and looks
like I'm naked or I think I put on a
thing that is like a shirt that is
regular and I am mistaken because when I
walk out everyone else like wow you have
really nice titties and you look naked
um
Kanye West White Bianca's story turns
head once again in risque sheer outfit
dude I need to get one of these outfits
straight up
just [__] with the [__] outline not
just the outline like an elephant trunk
like I have to fit you know how you put
fingers in gloves I need to put my [__]
in the outside of the thing
I mean she's looks naked dude that's so
gangster I want one oh I want one so bad
a man one
they got married after like a like
really quick she looks like King
Kardashian I mean you know
it's so crazy to be built like her huh I
mean she's
I mean the nipples are out actually this
is the most Italian [__] it's great okay
go for
okay well
I mean
God is obviously doing a new thing here
because I've never seen this before
it's crazy what's going on with Trump
and his [__] mug shot dude everything
they do just helps the situation I mean
I don't know if he's gonna be the next
president or not but
it's so crazy that no matter what
happens it just helps
like the guy was arrested put out a mug
shot and he he just did this [__] he was
like
and uh now people go ah I was con I was
uh charged once I'm gonna put
my mug shots on
up
look at this this is hilarious that
these people
I stand with President Trump against the
Kami D.A Fanny Willis who is nothing
more than a political Hitman task for
taking out Biden's top political woman
person you should not play and then she
puts
Marjorie Taylor green puts her thing up
now it's a badge of honor it's like what
were you arrested for you know
um
he's not going to face one day in prison
you know
if anybody the only Republicans can get
away with this if if a [__]
Democrat did this done he'd have to be
like I'm a republican now
fantastic
I love it and now I'm just told deep in
the headlines Joe Rogan declared this
look look at this headline Joe Rogan
declares Melania Trump the hottest first
lady of all time
okay well yeah she is you know
because who were the other ones who you
want to put her up against Nancy Reagan
the lady is hot she's hot professionally
podcaster says after hitting out a
report that the former first lady is
laughing off husband's legal controllers
dude
look at the way they [__] do this
Toronto
Joe Rogan is a big fan of former lady
Melania Trump
a former first lady Melania Trump
calling her the hottest first lady of
all time in our an article speculated
that she's disinterested in her
husband's recently I mean dude you know
um
she also is Far and Away the hottest
first lady right I mean who else would
come close Grover Cleveland's wife
like who comes close
a [__]
uh
Michelle Washington
or whoever the [__] he was married to
Francis Cleveland nah yeah it's between
her and Francis Cleveland
she took some awesome black and white
photos of her face back then woo
I can't stop jerking off to him dude
between Melania Trump and Francis
this other articles
um what about Francis Cleveland what
about Melania what about uh Michelle
Washington but I mean it's really going
with this Michelle Washington thing I
don't know her [__] I don't know who
it is
unreal
Martha Washington probably it was way
back then George
Washington
wife
Martha wow he knew it
God imagine being alive in 1700
George Washington's first wife
um
she died of a fever god dude
now it's gonna be that's going it's
gonna be like in in 300 years about
cancer they'd be like oh they died of
that back then [__]
um
crazy oh R.I.P Bob Barker by the way
what a great career he had I thought he
was dead already so that's so many
people I knew thought he was already
dead I hit the timer
um
and that's exactly how it should be by
the way sincerely you should live so
long that
if you're a personality that if you get
to the point to where like I'm done
working I don't want to do this that you
still have 10 more years and people
forget about you and think you probably
died and then you died be like oh yeah
that is the [__] way to die and it's the
best way to die because you get more
time than
just like you get to retire and have fun
you know a lot of people just die when
they uh
stop working like William Shatner he's
still doing [__] you drive by you see
Billboard's William shatlers William
Shatner's like this show now and that's
what it's called and you and you're like
oh when he stops working guy's gonna die
a week later he's gonna be like I'll
take a break oh that's how he's gonna do
it
that's how he's going to do it for real
you know I've been thinking about
slowing oh that's how you're gonna die
oh
and um
Bob Barker was just like
no
you know
I'll keep living for 10 years after I
stop working is that even how he sounds
kind of right yeah that's kind of how
he's Andre but that's like the vein of
it
um yeah like the last big thing he did
was Adam Sandler movie and then he did
the documentary on him remember they did
that documentary on him where it was
like whereas like nose was all [__]
red and [__] what the hell was that it
wasn't supposed to be about his red nose
but his nose was red a lot that happens
to old people you just get red
you know in certain areas your body your
skin part of your skin just like ah we
give up here on the forehead area
people with HIV get it way earlier but
people who just are regular that don't
have HIV they get to be a hundred and
then there's just parts of their skin
that are just like oh dude they're just
gonna [__] it you know what open up it's
too hard to keep together open up
and then their skin untethers and
there's like a sarlacc pit inside of it
and it's just like two
it's too much
shout out to old guys
none of these Twitter links work by the
way because I can't
I don't know why
they all say nothing to see here looking
for this
um but yeah so so shout out to Bob
Barker man he uh you know the price is
right baby and how many people are
making the joke where he died right
before a dollar you know right before
100 years 99 years without going over
um is that the [__] no that's not the
other one what's the other one the
surveys oh remember that guy
who was that that did that who was the
guy that did that uh that was Family
Feud right surveys house
but he killed himself right I think he
did
that makes so much sense that the host
of The Family Feud murdered himself
oh wait no you know what Bob Barker was
like no that's what it was Bob Barker
was let's see what's behind door number
two I do car that was what that was
a new car a new car but that's not Bob
Barker that's the other guy right
do you do that I don't think so I think
the announcer would do it the announcer
let me let me look at this up this is so
this guy was the number one announcer I
think
um what's his name uh what What's the
price is right price
car
[Music]
price is right is right announcer new
car I think Bob Barker says a new car
part
yeah here we go
nice to meet you now Josh my boy I'd
love to give you that
dude
[Applause]
[Music]
look at the car too here have you heard
about this [__] dude pleasure to me it's
nice to meet you now Josh my boy I'd
love to give you that
[Music]
hell yeah dude look at Roddy rods look
at Rod standing over there
calm cool
dude what
the [__]
does this guy look like oh my God a
[__] dick Tracy character
he's in a dress like Dale hulie dude
dress like a hundred percent what's his
name
um are you looking at him right now
dressed like Steve Harvey in 1995. on
[__] wearing the last thing Bernie
Mac wore before he deceased on believe
Roddy Rod smoked so many poles it's
unbelievable Roddy Rod was so gay and
it's okay but he was he would just be
like face [__] me
make me just I get off on you telling me
what to do I don't even need to go come
let's jerk off in you know
you look so bad
and collected but not so only a half
hour or so ago our beloved they're
having so much it was almost the head
over by an automobile on stage
it was a stick shift and the young lady
whose name I shall not mention in the
car doesn't know her break from her
clutch oh sexy ass dude she's a [__]
the only job she could have is a nurse
she's coming on stage the automobile
headed for Rod
and she kept stepping on the clutch
screaming the break won't work
God stood there smiling till the very
last moment and then believe it or not
oh man God left from the stage into the
audience nice dude
that's true he keeps saying dude this
guy wow I want a documentary on Roddy
Rod right now dude
it's called face [__]
I am happy to disrespectful he's dead
mistress make a Superman cake for him to
wear
it's a new truck
new coming well Bob this one nearly ran
me down it's the Mitsubishi Mirage
four-door sedan with a clutch
God it's so good dude rest in peace Bob
Barker rest in peace
Roddy Roddy Rod Rod Roddy Rod Roddy dude
wow a candy bar in the [__] 60s and
uh the new Rod Roddy with almonds
um killed it great
what's this one oh here's Roddy Rod
sorry well no I'm not sorry this is
funny [__]
hi a candelabra on your Podium over
there
thank you Bob thank you very much who is
our next player it happens to be Vic
Falls
[Applause]
right dude I wonder why they got this
guy to do it like just have Bob Barker
do it
in fact it helps
that's great
oh God TV was just different
huh remember appointment television dude
like if you wanted to watch a show you
had to [__] sit down at 9 00 pm
come on and you miss dude if you got
there late you missed it
what bro that's crazy I've I remember
that all right I'm 43 years old I
remember that and I still am like no way
no way
on freaking real dude
oh [__] this you know what dude I can't
believe I uh
what's his name came up with a new movie
Liam Neeson
movie
retribution it's called retribution of
course it is eh
it's called distribution
dude he has so many
he's gonna come out
with the movie called
dude it's retribution the other one was
like cold Pursuit he's gonna come out
with movie called distribution
are you gonna answer that
it's not mine
all this soft like lens tip
sorry who is this yep
did I do something to you you sound so
guilty what do you want drive to this
location wow honey Something's Happened
there's a man who's put a bomb in the
car he's got the best [__] nose I
know I've said this before
[Music]
we can't get up the car will explode
dude just
we're here listen very carefully or I
kill you open the glove box oh my Deans
in it dude
why are you doing this
what have I ever done to you this life
or yours Matt I'm your best friend
oh no dude
I mean doing the whole movie for us
yep there it is
107 you know for your clients who
invested in your phone oh she's good
yeah
I mean just so many cars exploding in
this video
in this preview you got everybody's
attention man
oh he is still out there if you can't
find him I will I'm in control here no
you're not you hurt my darling son of a
[__] I will kill you yeah dude I'm
gonna watch
Drive
shot the whole thing in Italy dude
unbelievable
they go like they I mean his agent must
just be [__] swim dude his agent just
must be getting sucked off in his pool
so much just not giving a [__] dude
wait a minute I'm in the car now
I wasn't a plane and now I'm in a car
he hasn't done a movie on a boat let's
get him in a boat
I'm in a boat
um
amazing dude
wow this tweet right here I mean you
know
I once tried to suck a guy off at an
alley behind the club all I remember was
his dick stayed flaccid in my mouth for
two minutes before he told me to stop
that's so imagine it's the first time
you become you're like okay I'm gay
I'm gonna go do this [__] it here we go
hey
let me get down on my knees let me start
doing this and then for two whole
minutes
you know like you know [__] equalizer
guy can kick how many people's ass could
he kick in two whole minutes in nine
seconds he took down Five Guys
so in two whole minutes this guy can't
even take down one guy sexually
in two whole minutes you know how many
people it would be more deaths than John
Wick and this guy can't even get a guy
not even to completion but hard
unreal once tried to suck a guy off in
an alley behind this so crap why are you
Tweeting this you know just like
keep a secret
like you know what's wrong with people
who just uh you know what I'll tweet
this one day that's the that's the they
broke one day I started to suck a guy
off and you know and now everyone knows
it
great tweet great tweet phenomenal tweet
honestly
here's the William Shiner thing
not only is it different than what you
thought
William shiner
you know what my
my
um William Shatner describing the awe of
space to Jeff
pesos
[Laughter]
so dick dude
I want to hear this here
do a little bit
doesn't give a [__] oh what a dick dude
Champagne Showers bro this is like
this is like would be it would be in the
office in the moment clearly
he should have said shut the [__] up
shut the [__] up give me this I want one
dude he just said I want one whip
shutter is like the awe of space you're
just shooting up and all the only thing
that's there it's between you and yeah
give me one of those things at spray
[__] shut up dude
[Music]
and then he did the thing
that laugh that he does the dude wow
he's worth like 800 100 what is he
billion dollars and [__] not what's he
worth 50 billion dollars
200 billion dollars dude
where's the [__]
now my sound plant's not working great
great doesn't work sometimes I want to
do the hell yes doesn't work
um
God that's great dude
I just love it
God what a great video that is that's a
phenomenal one I've never seen that one
okay okay
where's my Google Chrome come on baby
there we go
okay I asked Mike
team to get people getting pissed
uh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh this is ripe hold
on a second here we go hold on a second
attacked the girl he was with how's that
idiot learn how to drive
Richard
oh
you gotta be kidding me and then didn't
even go that far and stopped
he's gonna get out no right no of course
not
it's on
yeah look you're an idiot how's that
idiot how's that dude that's so Italian
how's that you're an idiot how's that
learn how to drive oh my God what an
ugly girl too
I mean girl had nothing to do with it
dude why that guy's got so many problems
man
God you're you're a work you're a bad
driver how's that oh what an ugly girl
too
unreal dude
unreal
there you go
people getting pissed love it who what
an ugly girl do and he goes uh
what's his [__] idiot doing
like like for real bro
she want me to hit her yo I just want
you to put the refrigerator in the house
dude she's under the person's car
on in front of her time you know what
white women straight up
only a white woman [__] or an old
Japanese man would do this kind of a
thing white women are Japanese men for
real and not in the mindset in the what
they'll do like a white woman will just
flagrantly be like you know what I'll
get under the thing I know you're not
gonna kill me right because they just
think that they're not and then the
person will just run them over an old
Japanese man will be like it isn't my
duty to risk my life for a refrigerator
there is
a Soviet
and then he would do it and then he
would die and as he was dying you would
think for to my family and as this white
woman would die she would think oh my
God what
it's not supposed to happen
with that thing we don't even have a
dolly
come on
look at this crazy [__] man
like look like for real bro
she want me to hit her you know I just
want you to put the refrigerator in the
house
with that thing we don't even have a
dolly
we don't even have a dolly she says what
a [__] [__] dude
somebody just comments lesbians
people getting mad this is a good
account
wow
white women are I didn't realize that
white women are also Japanese men that's
crazy that's a good observation thank
you
I've seen this
song
I've done this one all right dude
that's right
I'm not telling you my name I'm talking
about the police call the police on your
move I'm gonna go sit over here
oh my God I
swear to God
all right
yeah
all right dude I mean this skateboard
guy is just like come on man
and I caught your redhead I had to
replace one already you ruined that
okay [__] [__] who the hell are
you to touch other people's [__]
don't you think somebody has to pay for
that
that's unbelievable why did they stop
filming
this guy
loves his plants dude
I would have I
thought what would I have done in that
situation
somebody comments typical skater loser
being a loser you know
look at him run up
what my [__] Bush all right I always
put it back that's tough [__] I always
put it back
put me 50 [__] dollars
chill the [__] out man all right dude
that's right I wish they'd honestly what
the skateboarder did is [__] dumb
it's dumb if he keeps [__] up the
plants but holy [__] I wanted that guy
to get knocked out the owner
up in the club
come on let's do another one these are
great
she roasted them I mean I just want a
fish ma'am oh no no hell you can't fish
you ain't you don't know how to fish you
don't even wear the right kind of
clothes you got damn stupid shoes on
anyway where'd you get them ugly braces
you [__]
dude it's like how like like black 20
year olds do it she's doing it holy [__]
get your ass out of here
I mean I just want to fish ma'am oh no
no hell you can't fish you ain't you
don't know how to fish you don't even
wear the right kind of clothes you got
damn stupid shoes on anyway where'd you
get them ugly braces you [__]
why'd you get the [__] me pritches you
[__] she calls them britches holy
[__] dude this one's great where'd you
get them ugly [__] you [__] well
that's great dude what a good one oh
[__] these are funny as [__] huh
how come I can click on these Instagram
ones but not other ones
because they're individual too
oh wait this one
no I'm good see you know you lose [__]
it up so badly because I will beat your
[__] dick into the ground
I will beat your dick
dude how about
wow dude that's so good I would have
this this was me if he did that
get out of the truck little lady no I'm
good see cause you know you lose how do
I lose
because I will beat your [__] dick
into the ground all day long suck it
dude that'd be why don't you suck it
suck it nice
that's kind of dead the way the guy I
will beat your dick the way he stops
I will beat your dick dude
I'll beat your dick
I'll suck you off bro that that would
actually be good for fighting yo come on
man
let me suck you off bro
oh my god dude
I will beat your dick all day long
what a good are there other good ones on
that one
what a good thing
people getting what is it people what
well an account came up people getting
pissed at facts that's funny I bet
that's good
mad oh
wow
I'm gonna follow this one for sure
foreign
[Applause]
what's he trying to punch
[Music]
I mean that the state of that woman
Jesus Christ
the [__] state of that woman oh my
God old guy old guy with the [__]
old people don't give a [__] dude he
took a sledgehammer a little one of
those little sledgehammers to the truck
I want that truck off my lawn
oh he's doing it more
[Music]
bro I would
I would smash this dude what okay
oh just unload the cement on it
you're kidding me
he's ruining their work by walking
through the cement I hope he gets stuck
oh what a dick oh I'd [__] smash this
dude
I don't care how old
you can't get out
he kicked it out
no
he fell in
oh he's gonna die
oh
oh my
oh my [__] oh my god dude
he
oh my God
what a good account what if he just got
stuck in the cement and then
couldn't stop and then just became there
and and and and every time the people
drove by they were like that's the guy
that [__] you should learn a lesson
Remy got too mad and now he's cemented
like lips manless right before they
throw him in the [__] ocean in Dick
Tracy oh man when I was in when I was a
kid watched Dick Tracy that was one of
the scariest things I ever saw is when
they [__] put lips manless in the
cement tub and threw them in the I think
they
thought it might have been in the comics
but one of the guys they put in the
cement tub and put them in the ocean
and I thought that was the scariest
thing I ever [__] heard of in my life
when I was a kid
put cement boots on someone and just put
them in the
cement boots dude
and then it's like once I tried to suck
off a guy in an alley behind a club and
all I remember is his dick stay flat in
my mouth for two minutes before he told
me to stop you know
oh
God damn people getting pissed why is it
so funny
because it's because we relate to it why
is that so funny dude
[Applause]
this is from at an airport dude to get
people get so mad at an airport because
they they don't make they don't have any
the air rules of airports are so [__]
up they'll be like sorry you needed to
come a half hour early and you're like
huh it's right there and they're like
it's the rules they make it up as they
go dude sorry you're wearing a polo
shirt we can't what we can't you have a
polo shirt now we you need to pay for
the second bag
they make [__] up dude oh I [__] hate
Airlines
United's terrible but American is my new
kind of one that it's like update your
planes dude
twenty dollars for Wi-Fi
get your boy on the horn and get him
back here I'll write every single one of
you
every single one of you were called in
for passing on the burn passing in the
middle every single one sorry buddy he's
coming I know exactly who he is I'm not
playing it's not the one on the bike
though not the guy in the bank it was
[__] no no I'm saying that he was asking
me who I was on the phone with get his
ass back here
dude cops get so mad at people breaking
the rules like it's like personal for
them you know sometimes
it's personal for them one time a cop
pulled me over because I made a right
and I could have but I guess it was like
too close to a car or something he
pulled me over and I looked at him
and he said
the officer said Lewis it says on the
ticket I was like I I guess you thought
I was looking at his name man he was so
mad at me
wow cop's got other [__] going on you
know and then they have guns and you're
like uh oh I want all your ideas
yeah he's got him
wide
I don't want your explanation I want his
ass back here right now
you're getting arrested
breathing so hard this guy's so nervous
Jesus
fatal crashes oh my goddamn Interstate
12 times my Interstate you don't know
who he is every one of you is getting a
reckless off citation right now give me
your stuff
also like just okay you know just give
me the ticket
like not come back
every one of them for your Reckless
operation everyone
get him back here you can leave with a
piece of paper
you're done getting back here I'm taking
your bikes wow God damn dude somebody
said we need more cops like this
well if they were doing reckless [__]
that's stupid
my interstate is great
yeah I guess so somebody's saying the
fact uh 12 different people called 9-1-1
to tell them these guys were driving
recklessly 12. I could have killed
people or themselves yeah that's [__]
up [__] those [__]
Honestly by motorcycle guys are for the
most part they're so dorky dude
like they're so dorky me me me me me you
know uh all right that's good for this
one I appreciate you guys listening uh
that's it for YouTube if you want to
watch the rest of the show going over to
patreon patreon.com crystalia.com oh
sorry no patreon.com crystalia
um that's it and uh there's also a bunch
of other episodes there's like 30 plus
episodes there that get unlocked if you
sign up for just six bucks now uh so I
appreciate you I'll be in Nashville I'll
be in Little Rock Arkansas and Canada
and Detroit and Vermont and all sorts of
different places so come on by and uh
you guys uh thank you very much
appreciate you leave a comment
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]